[Music]
sapolsky's theory of human behavioral
biology claims that behind
every behavior is a biological process
that is the product of natural selection
if sapolsky is right this implies that
to truly understand human behavior
we would have to know exactly what
happens in the 100 trillion connections
of the brain
a nanosecond before the behavior occurs
and consider what took place
about 5 million years ago when humans
and chimpanzees shared their last common
ancestor
and all the stuff that happened in
between
for example when we see someone who has
done something wonderful and altruistic
or something brutal and savage we can
ask ourselves why did he do that just
now
[Music]
and when we ask that we are asking
something about what neurons in
different parts of their brain did a
fraction of a second ago
but we are also asking about what
environmental stimuli in the previous
seconds to minutes triggered those
neurons
and we are also asking what did hormone
levels in that morning have to do with
making those neurons more or less
sensitive to those triggers
and then we are often running into
neuroplasticity
how his experience changed those neurons
in previous months
[Music]
then you are back to adolescence and
childhood and all the way back into his
fetal life which has a huge amount to do
with what sort of brain we are going to
have as adults
and even further back genes come in and
culture because the way you were raised
within minutes of birth
reflects the culture that your ancestors
were coming up with centuries ago
[Music]
and at the bottom of the barrel why we
evolved into this kind of species
instead of that kind
if you trust sapolsky's theory of
behavioral biology
you may at this point realize that
things are much more complicated
while a simple sheeted a so heated b may
fulfill your need to bring order into
this chaotic world
it is likely not going to be the full
explanation
zapolsky was born in new york and he
spent his youth reading about and
imagining living with silverback
gorillas
by age 12 he was writing fan letters to
primatologists
and during high school he taught himself
swahili
later he spent 25 years observing the
same group of baboons in africa every
summer
and then went on to study and teach
behavioral biology at stanford
university
sapolsky left for those who try to
understand others the following advice
we are complicated so you better be
really sure
and really careful and really cautious
before you decide you
understand why somebody did something
especially if that is something you are
judging harshly
it's like trying to judge how a movie
got to its conclusion by only watching
30 seconds of it
what do you think is his theory solid
and can we actually never really explain
a behavior without taking the full
picture into consideration
or is there something like a soul that
takes decisions regardless of what
happens to us biologically
[Music]
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license
that means our videos are free and
anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools
governments and non-profit organizations
can also use them for training
online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts even one
dollar can make a difference